und jetzt schauen wir noch mal ein
bisschen tiefer rein wie viele patienten
liegen
aktuell auf den intensivstationen und
wir schauen hier auf die karte der
hospitalisierung noch einmal also
4203 corona patienten sind aktuell in
den krankenhäusern erfasst dass die
aktuellen zahlen vom
robert-koch-institut und dann rufen wir
uns noch mal in erinnerung was
eigentlich prognosen uns gesagt haben
vor weihnachten da war zum beispiel das
institut der intensivmediziner dass die
wie das hat davor gewarnt dass rund um
weihnachten wir
6000 patienten auf den stationen liegen
haben werden 6000 corona patienten das
robert-koch-institut hat gesagt dass es
etwa 5700 sein werden also das waren
damals die shop prognosen am anfang
dezember für diese zeit jetzt rundum
oder kurz nach weihnachten ich schreibe
die zahl nochmal auf 6.000 das war also
die alarm prognose von die wie von den
intensiv ärzten und ganz ähnlich auch
vom robert koch institut aktuell liegen
wir zum glück deutlich darunter bei
4203 und gleichzeitig greifen eben jetzt
diese verschärften maßnahmen die auf
basis dieser zahlen damals beschlossen
wurden brauchen wir die heute noch
darüber wollen wir jetzt diskutieren
hier im studio mit sandra und mit unser
bild meinung chef philippe piatti
ganz genau philipp ist bei uns herzlich
willkommen philipp was geht ihr durch
den kopf wenn du das siehst was ist das
schon wieder schief gelaufen ja man muss
es man muss es so hart sagen die shop
prognosen des robert koch instituts ist
die shop prognose der intensivmediziner
waren wieder überhöht waren wieder
falsch und dann gibt es einige
erstaunliche punkte ich glaube man kann
es keinem experten keinem institut keine
behörde übelnehmen dass sie sich mit
blick auf die nächste welle mehrere
monate im voraus verschätzt verrechnet
viele dinge kann man einfach nicht
berechnen und einigen müssen wir auch
froh sein dass es jetzt anders gekommen
ist aber trotzdem optionen wieder mit
den ängsten der leuten so gut da muss
man aber auch glaube ich diesmal
wirklich einmal streng sein dass nicht
konsequenzen los und uns vorbeiziehen
lassen denn man hat sich hier herr
modelliert verrechnet nicht in die
zukunft die nächsten monate sondern auch
in bezug auf die wenigen nächsten tage
am dritten dezember saß lka präsident
lothar wieler in der
bundespressekonferenz und hat gesagt
aktuell liegen 4800 personen mit corona
auf intensivstationen und die belastung
wird in den nächsten wochen steigen
wenige tage danach erreichte die zahl
der intensivpatienten mit 4.900 zu ihren
höhepunkt und fällt seitdem und das lag
mir ob er nochmal uns anschauen ferner
haben die grafik gerade schon gesehen
also zeit kurz noch mal ganz kurz was
waren die entscheidenden zeitpunkt
anfang dezember eben das war der
zeitpunkt wo die prognosen
veröffentlicht wurden auch von lkw chef
lothar wieler ne den erster zwölfter
genau am ersten zwölfter und am 2
zwölfter gab es die entscheidenden
prognosen vom tv und vom rk ii die haben
sich natürlich auch auf die maßnahmen
ausgewirkt denn am zweiten dezember kam
bund und länder damals noch unter
führung von bundeskanzlerin angela
merkel zusammen und maßnahmen zu
verschärfen da wurde bundesweit zweig
beschlossen da wurde de facto ein
lockdown für ungeimpfte beschlossen
basierend auf den prognosen
da hat michael müller noch gesagt ich
hoffe dass es uns mit diesen maßnahmen
gelingt die zuspitzung der situation auf
den intensivstationen zu verhindern und
dann wenige tage nachdem diese prognosen
getätigt wurden begann schon der
abschwung auf den intensivstationen und
das lag nicht an den beschlossenen
maßnahmen das war ja das argument der
befürworter dass sie sagen ja sieht
jedoch dass die maßnahmen gegriffen
haben da sagst du das kann gar nicht
sein der zeitraum war zu nichts möglich
wenn maßnahmen gewirkt haben wenn
maßnahmen wirken dann immer erst mit
einer verzögerung von mehreren wochen
bis sie sich auf den intensivstationen
bemerkbar machen also stellt sich
wiederum anders die frage brauchen wir
die maßnahmen jetzt überhaupt gar nicht
mehr und kann man die jetzt auch so
kurzfristig wieder abschaffen tja ich
möchte jetzt nicht den gleichen fehler
begehen wie das lka unter stevie und
meine eigenen prognosen stellen und
sagen ach wir kriegen das auch alles
ohne massnahmen aber wir brauchen da
mehr transparenz und wir brauchen auch
vielleicht nicht nur diese sogenannten
worst case kommunikation dass man immer
nur vom schlimmsten fall ausgeht denn es
gibt ein massives
glaubwürdigkeitsproblem
neben gerade wir haben maßnahmen
verschärft aufgrund von prognosen dann
stellt er sich kurz darauf für heraus
die prognosen waren komplett falsch und
jetzt haben wir neue maßnahmen
beschlossen verschärfen sie wieder
basierend auf weiteren prognosen wie
soll ich denn als bürger guten gewissens
sagen tja gut bislang lagen sie zwei mal
falsch aber dieses mal wird schon
stimmen so geht das nicht da muss die
politik aufklären da muss das lka
aufklären da muss die wie aufklären und
nicht so im jahr kann passieren
glücklich weil es ist anders gekommen
sondern wir müssen den den details
kennen und wissen wie konnte das
passieren und zwar immer und immer
wieder nun habt ihr ja auch das
robert-koch-institut angefragt auch die
intensivmediziner den verband der
intensiven ärzte sind die so drauf dass
die aktuell sagen ja gut also es kann in
der korona krise halt viel veränderung
geben an liegt nicht immer richtig in
dem moment lagen wir definitiv falsch
sind sie so ehrlich also das
robert-koch-institut hatte gestern auch
mal keine zeit um unsere anfrage zu
beantworten
die intensivmediziner vom die haben sich
geäußert professor doktor gernot marx
hat gesagt ja es ist nicht so
eingetreten wie von ihm und von seinem
medizinern prognostiziert er sagt
allerdings das lag daran dass sehr viel
mehr menschen auf der intensivstation
gestorben sind als von den modellieren
prognostiziert dh es wurden sehr viel
mehr betten frei weil unerwartet viele
menschen gestorben sind das ist erstmal
seine behauptung der gehen wir nach da
wollen wir auch alle daten wissen
wir müssen herausfinden was in diesem
dezember passiert ist warum alle
modellierer derart falsch lagen philipp
lass uns noch mal ganz kurz zum
abschluss über micon sprechen alle welt
spricht drüber wir warten auf diese welt
auf diese wand die angekündigt ist aber
auch hier passiert irgendwie nichts
genau also die mikrowelle wird
garantiert kommen wie in deutschland
werden nur als allerletzte merken weil
wir im daten blindflug sind das hat
präsident lothar wieler mit seinem
unerschütterlichen selbstvertrauen vor
einigen wochen bei der pressekonferenz
angekündigt wir werden jetzt einfach
erstmal ganz lange nicht wissen was los
ist auf den intensivstationen ja aber
die instanzen die sie können uns
wirklich in die haare schmieren die sind
einfach unvollständig die frage ist aber
nicht nur was passiert mit omikron denn
ich würde da herrn professor drosten dem
chef geologen der charité wieder
sprechen und sagen nein nicht omikron
schreibt die regeln wer das gesagt hat
sondern das machen immer noch wie er das
macht die politik das machen die
menschen die wir gewählt haben und da
ist die frage wie werden wir damit
umgehen werden wir wie die briten erst
mal locker bleiben boris johnson hat
gestern gesagt es wird mit mir erst mal
keine regelverschärfung geben im
gegenteil er verkürzt die quarantäne
dauer von zehn auf sieben tagen werden
wir das auch machen oder werden wir
schauen wie rooney konnten tatsächlich
einschlägt was infektion angeht dann
steht infizieren sich menschen ihre
kontaktpersonen müssen dann auch in
quarantäne und dann können irgendwann
tausende vielleicht hunderttausende
polizisten pfleger journalisten nicht
mehr zur arbeit